herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
märz heute zeige ich euch wie ihr kürbis
cache sommer an land die idee habe ich
im internet gefunden und ich fand die
kekse superstars im inneren sind sie
nämlich hohe und dann könnt ihr das
spiel für süßigkeiten einfühlen wie
smarties oder immun evans oder
gummibärchen und wer wissen möchte wie
man die kekse backt dann bleibt jetzt
dran zunächst zeige ich euch erstmal was
sie an zutaten benötigt an zutaten
braucht ihr 200 gramm mehl 100 gramm
butter und 50 gramm zucker und wenn ihr
möchtet dann noch etwas vanillezucker 1
1 und 1 teelöffel backpulver und zur
dekoration braucht ihr noch
lebensmittelfarben einmal in grün und
dann noch so ein orang strom den man in
zucker können die dann zum zucker mit
dazugeben und das backpulver mit zu mir
und danach vermischt ihr einfach alle
zutaten miteinander
und das verknetet ihr dann zusammen mit
eick das könnte auch einem elektrischen
mixer machen
den weg den jetzt hergestellt habe das
ist ein basis rezept ein grundrezept und
außerdem könnt ihr auch dieses ganze
buttergebäck hersteller mit plätzchen zu
weihnachten oder ihr könnt daraus einen
kuchen backen und auch vieles mehr
ich habe es leider vergessen noch etwas
zitronenschale mit in den teig zu geben
das könnt ihr natürlich auch machen
ich finde dann schmeckt auch viel besser
und aromatischer vom teig nennt ihr euch
jetzt eine kleine menge weg etwa so in
golfballgröße und dieses stück werden
wir dann gleich grün ein und das große
stück fed jetzt in orange ein
ich nehme dazu jetzt hier dieses geld
von wilden und vermischt es dann auch
noch mit einem bislang aus
und für das grün nehme ich jetzt hier
auch wieder von wilden dieses lief green
danach nehmen wir euch frischhaltefolie
und packt den teig an und gebt den für
etwa 30 minuten in den kühlschrank
nach einer halben stunde nehmt ihr euch
den teig wieder aussuchen kühlschrank
heraus und ich wollte ihnen dann immer
ganz gerne auf seiner bank folie aus
oder auf backpapier dann braucht ihr
nämlich weniger mehl beim ausrollen
also ihr braucht jetzt ein hilfsmittel
eben ein nudelholz und dann die
aussteller hier habe ich so ein 3 assets
ich finde das passt ganz gut auf dem
foto waren ja die kürbisse auch so
gewinnt und dann braucht ihr auch noch
in runden ausstecher falls ihr diese
grinten förmchen ich habt könnt ihr auch
ganz normal runde aus sicher nehmen
in drei verschiedenen größen debug folie
besteht ich jetzt ganz wenig mit mir und
ich fange jetzt mal mit dem
orangefarbenen zeit an
da kommt auch ganz wenig mehr darüber
und ich möchte nicht ungefähr zwei bis
drei millimeter dick ausrollen
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr euch dazu zur
hilfe so zwei china essstäbchen nehmen
und die lege ich mir dann nebenan und es
sind sozusagen meine abstandshalter also
ich werde dann den teig nicht dünn
ausrollen als die stäbchen und damit das
ganze nicht an meine zeit kommt als auch
noch eine back folie drüber und dann
könnt ihr das so ganz einfach ausfallen
und jetzt habt ihr dann gleichmäßig
ausgerollten teig und damit jetzt gleich
noch anheben lebt plötzlich den einstieg
anderer seite bin ich schon einmal um
den schnellsten ausstieg genutzt sich
später für das grün den lege ich jetzt
weg und jetzt brauche ich zwei mal die
großen ringe
das sind die mittel teile und zweimal
die kleine ringe jeweils für einen
kürbis
und die großen ringe die bekommen jetzt
noch das loch in der mitte und es macht
ihr mit diesem rollenden ausstecher
wenn jetzt an soweit habt dann nehmt ihr
euch den teig am besten mit so nem
tortenheber und dann kommt er auf ein
vorbereitetes backpapier und hier nimmt
jedoch die mitte heraus
wenn ihr das dann hab ich mach dir das
gleiche mit dem grünen teil
aber da brauchte jetzt nur den decken
also dieses grün auf den kürbis wieder
die zwei stäbchen
ich habe eben gemerkt es geht gar nicht
so arg dyk und da habt ihr jetzt aber
nur die kleinste form von den dreien
das war die mitte der stadt deckel und
der boden und das ist jetzt die kleinste
form
die brauchen wir für diskussionen
bei den grünen decken müsste jetzt noch
ein loch ausstechen
das mache ich jetzt einfach mit so einer
spritzt fühle da stecke ich mir jetzt
einfach das loch heraus
und für das grün in der mitte wollt ihr
euch den restlichen teig so von einem
kleinen hof
und da kommt jetzt die dicke darauf an
je nachdem wie großes loch in der mitte
ist und von daher schneidig holz einfach
mal so ein zentimeter gut und 115
zentimeter an
und ich denke von der titel her dürfte
es dann auch hinkommen
die plätzchen wir müssen jetzt bei 190
grad etwa acht bis zwölf minuten
gebacken werden
ihr müsst einfach mal schauen ob sie
durch sind oder nicht und auf keinen
fall zu lange erwachsen wenn ihr eure
kekse nach dem backen auf so abkühlen
liter geht dann kühlen die viel
schneller ab ohne könnte schneller
dekorieren werden die kekse jetzt noch
auskühlen müssen wir schon mal den
zuckerguss herstellen und was ihr dazu
benötigt eigentlich jetzt dazu braucht
ihr einfach ein bisschen puderzucker so
etwa 2 ist drei esslöffeln wobei zwei
trifft schon genug und mit zitrone und
staffel braucht ihr eigentlich nur ein
teelöffel ungefähr vom saft
es verbietet uns schon wieder anders und
der gus da soll doch ziemlich zähflüssig
sein also ziemlich dickflüssig und damit
man dann später nicht raus können gut
kommt auch noch ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe rein
den bussen gibt dieser ins um ein big
spritzbeutel und wenn ihr sowas nicht
hab dann nimmt einfach einen kleinen
gefrierbeutel das geht genau so gut da
musste dann einfach den bus in eine
spitzen filmen zum einen führen könnte
seien kleine aufnehmen und dann
verkleckern auch gar nichts
mit streicht dem bus noch schön vor zur
spitze
und dann könnt ihr ihn verschließen
indem er das ende zusammen zwei wollt
dann könnt ihr danach ganz schön damit
arbeiten
nach dem backen nehmt ihr euch dann
jeweils zwei ringe und zwei von den
kleinen keksen und jeweils einen grünen
deckel und einsteiger und die spitze von
der tüte könnt ihr dann aufschneiden
eine ganz kleine spitze braucht ihr
jetzt da nur und dann kommt einfach ein
bisschen von dem bus auf den unteren
decks
und da setzt jetzt einen ring obendrauf
da kommt dann noch mal groß drüber
und da kommt der zweite ring und den
grünen deckel den verbindet ihr mit dem
orangen und stadt füllt ihr ihn die
öffnung noch etwas groß rein und steckt
den stängel hinein
und da jetzt kein bus mehr drauf weil
das könnt ihr dann später absetzen und
so machte jetzt noch die restlichen
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr dann die
kürbisse mit süßigkeiten füllen so wie
hier ich glaub smarties oder immun ms10
bestimmt ganz gut drin aus diesem jahr
recht farbenfroh oder ihr könnt ihr auch
andere sachen da drin verstecken
ich habe das video hat euch gefallen und
das rezept inspiriert euch zum
nachmachen
ich denke in richtung weihnachten werde
ich die idee vielleicht nochmal
aufgreifen und gefühle tannenbäume draus
machen und mündlicher viel spaß und
jetzt würde ich ja viel spaß beim
nachbacken und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss